okay
[Music]
it
[Music]
[Music]
david
thank you thank you
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
it's my favorite show
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
time
[Music]
nobody that's a leader would not do what
i did
and i know there's a risk there's a
danger but that's okay
i just left walter reed medical center
and i learned so much in coronavirus
don't
be afraid of it you're going to beat it
we have the best
medical equipment don't be afraid of it
felt great like better than i have in a
long time
be afraid of it i didn't feel so good
don't be afraid of it you're going to
beat
don't be afraid of it and now i'm better
maybe i'm immune i don't know be afraid
of it don't
let it dominate don't let it take over
your life be afraid of it
don't let that happen you're the
greatest country in the world afraid of
it
and your leader i had to do that i knew
there's danger do it but i had to do it
but don't let it dominate your lives get
out there
be careful we have the best medicines in
the world
and it all happened very shortly and
they're all getting approved
and the vaccines are coming momentary
[Music]
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
[Music]
lives
convalescent flows with strong
antibodies
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
infection convalescence
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives provided 48 million dollars to
fund the mayo clinic study that tested
the
efficacy of convalescence
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we find
ourselves here once again it is a friday
night and we are into the last
uh what is it about 16 uh
17 days until the presidential election
between donald trump and joseph r biden
jr we are waiting
in macon georgia donald trump taking off
from
florida a little bit late from his last
rally but it's only
reportedly a 40-minute flight so we're
monitoring four
different streams for trump's arrival
scheduled for 20 minutes from now
i i actually think it may start not that
much after 7 15 because
even though trump was running late it is
a short flight uh but trump was
scheduled to i guess just sort of
sit in the plane for a half hour the way
it was originally scheduled sort of
weird
but needless to say we are all here now
i have
so many announcements uh to make
and different things that are going on
first and foremost
yes i will carry the second presidential
debate on thursday night
live and i have a few things to say in a
moment about some of the high marks
we've been getting
and i'll explain what that means in a
little bit but yeah we plan to do it
uh we've been given clearance by
clarence
and um we're we're ready to go so that
will be thursday there's a bunch of
rallies between now and then and my
my sense is that the streams will get
pretty frequent over the next uh
very short period of time because we
don't have that much longer until the
election and then i think that
my channel will probably die after the
election as many
patriots email me every day to tell me
so
there will be plenty plenty of streams
um
different things to go over
uh oh cv a superchat says i've heard you
mentioned thomas sowell a few times will
we ever do a video about about him
refuting him
would be cool if you could get him on
the show yeah maybe yeah we'll we'll uh
we'll look into that
a couple different things i want to
mention number one
coronavirus is back i don't know how
many of you
uh remember that uh there is still
a a pandemic going on and we now
are once again regularly in the united
states 65 000 cases back up to nearly a
thousand deaths a day again
and you will see if you look at the
cases and the moving average
we had this thing uh that happened
in mid april called the peak
and then when we peaked things
turned around very slowly and we saw a
decline down to about 20
000 cases a day and when we got down to
20 000 cases a day in early june had we
kept going
the model suggested we could really have
this under control by july 1st
everything opened so then as if 35 000
cases a day wasn't enough we had a peak
all the way up to 70 000 cases a day and
then again
things started closing and we started
seeing the effects of all the different
measures
and we got all the way back down
to 35 000 cases a day notice that
the peak peak number one
was lower than the bottom after peak
number two
and then again republicans said let's
just go completely crazy let's open
schools let's go completely bonkers
and then now we are all the way back up
to 66 000 cases a day yesterday
65 000 cases today and we may well be on
the path to 100 000 cases a day you know
when fauci talked about it months ago we
could see a hundred thousand cases a day
by the fall
all these these right wingers laughed
we're not gonna see a hundred thousand
cases well
look at the trajectory look at the
trajectory in one month
nearly doubling from 35 000 a day to
almost 70
70 000 a day so it's completely out of
control the deaths
fortunately uh have remained relatively
low
like a thousand a day uh but as you can
see if you look at a seven day moving
average it is flat
and two to three weeks after case spikes
you you tend to start seeing a death
spike now hopefully we're better at
treating it
hopefully we understand protocol
hopefully we you know it won't go as
what a weird ad by the way worried about
fatty liver that's a what is that an
aardvark
um hopefully we won't see that but in
all likelihood it is it is going to
start to happen so
yes the coronavirus pandemic very very
much
uh still a factor charlie says via
super chat from the standpoint of tippy
top nuclear
we're totally screwed if trump wins
reelection hair looking great as per
usual vote vote thank you
tomorrow by the way if so listen
typically i reserve
my uh instagram for
um produce and produce related pictures
so like if you look at my last two
pictures on instagram
here's a picture of me very very
strongly picking apples i picked some
uh i don't know if it's makhan or meikon
um
my friend nate here asking about
honeycrisp and i said never
i mean never ever ever why honeycrisp is
not on uh it's not part of what we're
doing
but picking apples then this is my
backyard
tomato bounty which i'm ripening in a
box
tomorrow i am going to take a break from
the non-politics on instagram because i
am going to be filling out my absentee
ballot
and delivering it to city hall it will
all be filmed
and by that i mean i will post one
picture okay so if you want to see that
tomorrow
you can follow me on instagram but yes
vote vote vote is indeed
the message that is indeed the message
uh let me close that out i have all
these things
i actually plan people might not know
but i actually take the streams
like if i'm going to stream i don't just
pop on
and you know whatever you know that some
other streamers might do
i have notes i have legal pads i have 10
tabs open because i i uh you know i'm
taking these streams
seriously but vote vote vote and that'll
be tomorrow okay
nina kaytel says in his rally earlier he
said ilanomar is an illegal
alien and she married her brother or
something jeepers i have a clip from the
earlier rally which i will play not that
one
mr zoo says john kasich republican
governor is another trump aborter
yeah i did a clip earlier about
massachusetts republican governor
charlie baker
saying he will not be voting for donald
trump and i believe that is true john
kasich is another one
jacob fry says you inspired me to do
political cemetery
oh comment commentary i think is what
jacob means
get doing good bro get doing good bro
you are amazing stay mad all right very
good
uh and then luke says first team will
very likely have their hands full
correcting the bs
the terror mango caused greetings from
europe luxembourg
good luck guys luxembourg is not a place
i've ever been to but i would love to go
i would absolutely love to go so that's
all happening very exciting
really appreciate it over on twitch we
are back on twitch
uh liquid ice has subscribed for 12
months zyllis
ndg has subscribed lillian so
bailey lukens libero
zamila insomnia jones
jolt bit craft
schmevel all these different people
subscribing over on twitch which we love
we are back
back on twitch and then before we move
on very quickly
thanks to eric yvonne's
austin smith and candace marshall
who are new members one two and three
beautiful numbers one two and three
at joinpackman.com okay
uh remember yesterday that completely
out of control nodding sycophant i
immediately identified her behind donald
trump and it didn't seem normal
just nodding it was like her head was
going to be oh my god my hair
actually i hadn't had an error because
of my head bobbing
uh she was clearly a sycophantic lunatic
and indeed she was uh myra jolie
identified as nodding woman at town hall
i guess it's somebody that trump knows
there's some article i read about how
she said hi to trump or something like
that and i got a very interesting email
from one of our viewers
who told me about um uh what was the
hold on let me see the exact term
he told me the term um
nodding where was it i want to make sure
i get the term right
oh yeah okay nodding manipulation said
to google it
and indeed there is a ton of literature
about nodding raising likability and
approachability both
if you are doing a lot of nodding you
become more approachable and likable
to others if you know you meet someone
at a business networking event
imagine if people still did business
networking um
and you you know people are talking to
you about oh you know i sell
insurance do you need life insurance
like these networking events that i've
stopped going to
because everybody's selling insurance
all the time and you go yeah oh wow
whole life yeah fascinating premium oh
yeah you get a commission beautiful
it makes you seem more likeable and
approachable but the other effect of
that is
if you see a politician speaking and
there's a crowd of people around them
nodding about everything they say
so at a subconscious level again if you
are know to resist it if you know to
look for it it's a defense mechanism but
if you don't
you will perceive what the politician is
saying more positively if there's a
crowd of people around
nodding and as far as you know it is it
is genuine nodding so very interesting
and maybe even a topic to cover
on uh on monday okay so we've got that
and then we've got that all right
earlier today at the rally that trump
did
in florida this is a perfect example
okay
so don jr tweeted this let me just see
if we're missing anything
uh no nothing happening yet don jr
tweeted this this is
trump is speaking he's reading off his
prompter um
and he i guess notices a hundred year
old veteran in the crowd and then he
interrupts the rally
and there's a standing ovation okay
let's look at it and i have some
thoughts about this
and by the oh before we do that
there's this big controversy about when
we're watching these events
should i mute them or should i pause
them to talk over them
one of our i believe european viewers
wrote to me and said david
there is a filter you can add
where instead of muting when you talk
streamlabs obs will turn down the audio
you're listening to
so let's just test it here okay the idea
is that i don't have to touch anything
if i want to mention something while
trump is speaking i can just talk and
my system will turn down trump's voice
let's test it and see if it works
but now the democrats are testing one
two three four five
ever put forward by a president it did
lower it about half i don't know if for
you guys it's the right amount of
of reduction i can tweak that if you
guys think oh people think that that's
right that it
wow wow i'll leave it then
i won't touch it um
okay good all right excellent so let's
continue so we'll have that i think
that'll be a great tool for future
streams let's listen presidential
nominee you know it's an amazing thing
this is the weakest presidential
oh go ahead say it go ahead
100 year old veteran right here
right
wow
so this is the exact type of thing that
is is disgusting
not honoring a veteran the use of it the
right is both disgusting with this stuff
but they also are just
kind of good at it right you get the
whole everybody's going crazy and they
forget wait a second
what's trump's health care policy how
many tens of millions of people lose
health care if trump gets his way
wait a second how many times has trump
uh
um uh you know and people around him
violated the hatch act
it's irrelevant to policy but
republicans are good at this stuff
and um it it is just a perfect exam you
know then donald trump jr
signal boosts it and it's it's
they know how to do this stuff and they
do it they do it all the time and
unfortunately
it seems to work um at least to some
degree
okay we are standing by for donald trump
in macon
is it macon or macan georgia
joja as some say uh
anybody know me i think it's making the
apples are macan right
macon okay macon people are telling me
it's making
me khan hmm okay very good
um so this one says it's been delayed
this one says it hasn't
this one oh let's see what joe biden is
saying this election remind me of
something my dad used to say said joey a
job's about a lot more than a paycheck
it's about your dignity it's about
respect it's about your place in your
community to be able to look your child
in the eye
and say honey is going to be okay and
mean it
well that's a lesson never i've never
forgotten
that's what i grew up surrounded by
hard-working families
in scranton pennsylvania claymont
delaware
how many people today though can look
their kids in the eye and say
everything's going to be all right and
mean it
these times are hard unemployment is way
up
due to the pandemic just this week
over a million 200 000 more people file
for unemployment
the economic outlook for next year
remains uncertain
and across michigan and the country
folks are worried about making their
next rent payment or their mortgage
payment or their car
payment they're worried whether or not
they can purchase the prescription drug
they need
or put food on the table have to make a
choice worried about sending their kids
to school
worried about not sending their kids to
school right
they see the people at the top doing a
hell of a lot better
while the rest of her left to wonder
who's looking out for me
that's donald trump's presidency more
than 215 south i think
so very very interesting yesterday as
you guys all know there were
there were dueling town halls last night
and joe biden
had better ratings than donald trump and
i i don't
know for sure that um
i i don't know for sure that there was
um
anything trump has said publicly about
it but
um i can't imagine trump likes that
because trump is all about trump is all
about ratings as all of you very
very much know okay i want to
communicate a concern and the concern is
about voter registration um
i actually don't think it's clear that
um you are going to see the
major easy victory for joe biden that
some are
predicting and i'm really looking at
two things there are some new polls
like for example if we look at the
latest polls from today
there is a hill harris x pole which has
florida tide
there is a florida pole that has biden
plus three
um pennsylvania after being up more
it's biden plus five uh okay michigan
biden plus 11 is very powerful trump
plus one that's a republican poll
north carolina is now tied if north
carolina carolina's tide going in i
think trump wins it
and combine this with voter registration
data where
new republican registrations in a number
of these key states i don't remember
exactly i'm going to look at them for
monday's show
but in some key states republican voter
registration has been outpacing
democratic voter registration
we know that that's public data that's
not a poll that's that's
actual data so i mean listen uh anybody
who's super confident about what's going
to happen uh november 4th
november 3rd when is the election the
third right yeah november 3rd
um i i want to hear your confidence now
there are people who will say
you know the difference david is for
example
biden's only plus five but he has 51.
hillary was not at 50 in a lot of these
places okay well look at
biden in florida is 48 and 48.
uh biden in north carolina is 49.
when i see the challenger not at 50
against an incumbent president it
doesn't make me particularly confident
and i know every time i talk about this
people will email me
they'll say oh david you're gaslighting
you're making people
think it's going to be close so that
they'll vote
wow how evil i'm trying to get people to
vote but i i'm not
i'm not exaggerating my concern about
about the numbers
uh it's it's just it's just the way i
see it and i think that anybody
if you're expecting joe biden to win the
popular vote by nine or ten i
i mean i'm not a betting man but i think
i would take that bet
i would bet against that i'm being
notified that we have a lot of people in
the chat that need to be banned
uh who's who's trolling let's see
it looks like we do need to ban some
people um
we need to ban everybody well we're not
going to do that but
yeah if people are getting aggressive
let me know we will drop the banhammer
very strongly
moderators please take notice because it
does we don't want we don't want that
stuff going on there
big thank you to sarah hines who is new
member number four today at
joinedpakman.com very much appreciate
that
let's get to some additional super chats
that are coming in i don't want to fall
behind there a lot of messages coming in
from people
let's see here oh whoops i missed a
bunch of them
um hold on here
okay ford says two and a half weeks away
both excited and nervous of course
of course eric says north carolina
voting report waited about three hours
but was not required to crawl over
broken glass that's good i mean i would
be willing to crawl over broken glass to
vote but i would prefer not to
so i'm glad you were not you didn't need
to
walker anderson says are you going to
condemn the democrats for filibustering
covid relief or does only lefty news
make the cut
um if if you look at my uh commentary
on that issue uh there is no shortage of
criticism
um for both sides uh but but you know
when you look at
i mean trump and republicans can't even
get on the same page so ultimately what
does it matter what demo i mean when
mitch mcconnell says we are not doing
more relief
does it really matter if nancy pelosi
would accept 1.9 but not 1.8
right i mean let's let's think
critically here my friends nicholas says
farron cousins on ring of fire today
said david
parkman is more entitled to a nobel
prize
than donald j trump i saw that i saw
that in fact we could look at that real
quick if you guys want to
um let's see nobel
um i got an email about this
from the standpoint of medical that's
not what i'm looking for
where was nobel
uh here it is okay good yeah let's check
this out this is our good friend
farin cousins uh let's listen to what he
had to say
he made a beautiful point in fact let's
take a look at it i think it was about
the three minute mark
published they do tend to get nominated
because literally anyone on the planet
can be nominated for it
you know you you didn't win anything
special by being nominated
i i'm pretty sure that you know uh a
youtuber
who's far more popular than me like uh
david pakman for example could probably
get more votes
for nobel peace prize than you and he
would certainly be more deserving of it
than donald trump is and of course he
had to throw in the digs at obama
because the republicans loved
all right so very nice uh glad to see
glad to see a very strong statement
there
from uh from farren always good to see
thank you to fab i
am and kiehl's who for the twitch subs
robot laser party subscribed and sent me
the message
guess who voted today this guy that is
great news
also thanks to chaotic stasis for the
twitch prime
sub uh oh brian coldy is here brian
coldy my
um brother-in-law by domestic
partnership twice removed i got the wife
to finally watch the show that is a huge
accomplishment
um major major news oh and it's actually
it's it's called these i believe it's
coldy's sister's birthday today
very exciting day in the coldy family a
lot of accomplishments there
c asks whether i vote blue all the way
down the ballot or do i vote for charlie
baker for governor charlie baker's not
on the ballot
um double ddb says hey david if you
haven't you should watch winston peters
the new zealand vpm answering a covid
denier
it shows how america is viewed by other
countries if somebody can get me a video
of that i would be interested in
checking that out
naba says hallo david from your friend
from pakistan i have chicken to trade
now guys that's not i i don't like that
we have real callers from pakistan
actually um
speaking of which um
[Music]
pedro from colombia called in again
and it is wild uh let me see if i can
find it here because it is it is
something else
uh this has not published yet unless
you're a member if you are
if you're a member then this is already
published but
if you're not i am going to preview this
for you guys we have not heard from him
for a while let me just see what's
happening here
uh okay nothing so far okay so let's
take a look here i think you guys will
enjoy this this is pretty interesting
oh my god i can't even see my own videos
hold on a second uh all right let me
just uh let me get signed in here
just so everybody can see this
all right and we are almost back
news voice is the world's okay hold on
all right we're gonna skip my own ad
check this out this is something else
this was a great call actually we hadn't
heard from him this was by discord so
you can hear him really well too
dot com slash discord that is
d-i-s-c-o-r-d
let me bring on our friend this is an ex
global exclusive pedro from
colombia pedro como esta
[Music]
hola mr pacman can you hear me
i i can hear you yes
mr pacman it's been a long time you know
uh i got the corona a few months ago
and then it was kind of sad and then my
my wife she left me for a little bit but
so he actually does understand spanish i
asked him what his contagion date was
and he said it was in july
but you do speak some you actually do
speak some spanish it sounds like
oh yeah mr fakman i i speak spanish but
i try to
speak english too okay and
what were your symptoms quality
oh you know my my head hurt you know
i was like oh no i can't can't get up
here
today you know
oh i don't know it was like a hundred
or something mm-hmm okay
but you know i feel better now and you
know my
my wife she was gone so she didn't get
sick it was just
me and perrito you know now when you say
your wife left you
she left you just temporarily while you
had the kovid or she just
you're no longer with her oh she was
like
man she just got mad at me and you know
but she was i'm trying to understand she
was mad you had the virus or she was mad
about something else
oh she gets mad at me for a lot of
things that that was one reason she got
mad at me
right and remember remind me where in
ecuador are you from
no from colombia oh from colombia okay
very good but
i'm in texas and i'm looking forward to
buying
winning taxes my question for you is
do you think biden has a chance in texas
listen i think he has a chance and joe
biden recently made the decision to
start spending a bunch more money in
texas he's also sending kamala harris
down there so
i think by it's close enough that biden
has determined it's worth making a play
for it uh i i if you say bet money david
who wit just even money who wins texas
i still think trump wins texas but
forcing trump to have to defend it
is a great thing oh yes
you know i hope i hope i didn't win i
hope
kamala harris when she's kind of cute
you know
right well you know i i appreciate
talking to you mr pacman i love your
your discord and there's some very nice
people there
all right pedro from and you're from el
capital right you told us
no mr buckman i just had a headache that
day i didn't remember where i'm from
where are you from in colombia i have a
headache now and i don't remember where
i'm right wrong
[Music]
was it where was it you'll tell me next
time okay
all right all right guys so there it is
a global excuse exclusive premiere that
is the latest
pedro from colombia call and
where that guy is actually from we we
literally may never know it's a
um it's a mystery like uh the bermuda
triangle quite frankly
okay mile high hustle says what happens
between election day and inauguration
day of trump loses nice apples by the
way
i have no idea i'm taking oh that
actually that's one of my other things i
wanted to mention so i
i need you guys to just be very very
real with me and tell me whether i'm
being naive
okay um people are already saying i
haven't i haven't given you the premise
yet let me give you the premise first
before you tell me that i'm being naive
so a lot of our broadcast partners you
know free speech tv
youtube all these different people they
want to have calls with me which is
great i love having calls all the time
but they want to talk about what they
are expecting to be a crisis situation
during the transition period so a lot of
these
folks have gotten it into their heads
that between election day and
inauguration day
it's going to be completely insane
they're talking about do i need
reporters on the ground were there going
to be legal challenges do i need this do
i do you know what what do we need to do
i actually think there's a realistic
possibility that either
trump just gets re-elected uh or biden
wins by
you know a relatively healthy margin not
a 10-point thing
10-point 10-point victory and it's not
going to be that crazy like is it am i
the naive one here
who thinks it's possible things will get
crazy but things might also not get
crazy like everyone's going completely
nuts
nobody knows okay i am naive okay very
good
excellent um it might be fine
things will not get crazy everything's
gonna be fine
i'm i'm navi no i i'm asking whether i'm
naive not navi
uh okay all right so we do have live
video now from this trump event
uh oh joe biden is saying bye with his
mask
oh the audio's been cut and that was joe
biden there in michigan
as we continue to bring you coverage
here of joe
uh doing democracy 2020 campaign style
there in the battleground
all right very good so now we are
waiting for trump let's see if we have
audio
oh my god okay um so all right anyway
we'll see i
i'm we're going to be prepared for any
eventuality of course after
the election but um i i think there's a
chance it doesn't get that crazy
okay we have a coveted crowd in macon
georgia where we are expecting donald
trump
absolutely any minute i want to say
thank you to cedric bogardus
for the join pacman.com subscription
your new member number five
michael lilla is new member number six
daniel
galpin is number seven kieran pace
is number eight and rebecca gutierrez
is new member number nine at
joinedpakman.com
head on over grab a membership let's see
what else is on
folksminds um via youtube super chat
matt humphrey says have you ever
interacted with howie carr in any way
no i can't imagine two more polar
opposite individuals i have never
interacted
with howie carr christopher scott says
deepak drop in the
amazing beats amazing
zachary ezioni says quickest pro-israel
argument i
what do you i don't even know what that
means do you mean the quickest argument
for why israel should exist as a country
that's like a crazy that who's
that it seems insane to even debate that
uh if you can tell me
more of what you mean if you're just
saying what is the explanation for why
israel
gets to exist it would be i guess
countries are created in three ways
acquiring territory through war a
purchase
or international treaty those are the
three ways
any country is created and israel was
created one of those three ways
just like every other country um but i
guess i'm not sure
i know what you mean taylor clark says
imagine a lunatic biden fanatic like
some of these trumpers flying
biden fight for the soul of the nation
flags and screaming about ice cream
yeah if if biden supporters did the
things trump sycophants do
um my guess is police end up at their
houses
to be perfectly frank chase axelsson
says just voted for the first time
yesterday down ballot dem
don't forget to look at the back
sometimes there are additional races to
vote in yes very often there are
or questions binding or non-binding
tom denny with a brutal
50 super chat the largest of the evening
says trump's rally was next door to my
house today
in ocala florida it's even worse in
person i can only imagine
jake says that i see the cleveland ohio
printing company that makes ballots
that are being delayed they fly a trump
flag in the photo
used in the new york times i did not see
that
i will look at it between now and monday
uh jorah monathan where was that jorah
monathan says hey the masks you sponsor
with vents aren't accepted on flights
now what are your thoughts incorrect
the our mask oh by the way um
we have so many sponsors renewing
everything they're like can we
we have a crazy situation where we are
if i don't want to speak out of turn
for our business development uh um
chief noah ferguson uh what are these
guys doing by the way
what are these two guys doing
are they uh is it a mic test or are they
putting trump's speech up i guess
okay um we are we essentially are full
for advertisers
can you if through the end of the year
like if someone came to us right now and
said
i want to buy 20 spots or something like
that we would have to say
we need to talk to our existing
advertisers and see if anybody's willing
to
you know maybe like we're full okay
because things are going crazy
including our mass sponsor our mass
sponsor sussman and han offers a vented
mask
it is not the kind that is not accepted
on flights it is a
filter vented mask and those are
those are okay by the cdc the vent is
something related to the
air i don't it but it's not one you you
have a full filter inside of the mask
that's replaceable
in addition to the vent we looked at it
very strongly with them
and everything everything's cool uh
richard says uk viewer been watching for
a while love the show
thank you um jamie says i live in
upstate new york and the voting lines
are foreign to me i've never had to wait
more than five minutes to vote
listen even voting in boston i've never
had to wait more than five minutes to
vote but th that that this is the whole
point that you have
two completely different circumstances
uh phil says david why don't you have
gopro premium so you don't have ads
gopro the hell does that mean
gopro premium i don't have a gopro
i don't even know what that means don
says early voting
maybe i'm being naive or navi i don't
know don
says um early voting done today in north
carolina for blue but in the small town
of franklin north carolina
is more red than blue all right thank
you for letting me know
uh looks like we have sort of a pool
shot here
we'll stick with it love and music says
did you see someone put official
republican ballot box on garbage cans in
california
yes i did absolutely vile arnold
schwarzenegger
actually said today california
republicans have lost their minds or
something like that very very funny to
see him
uh turn on them core says true story i
filled out my ballot put it in my purse
yesterday this morning it's gone i'm so
upset i didn't leave my house after work
what the hell
yeah i would talk to uh you know maybe
your dog ate it i don't know
septic avenger says just voted for biden
do you think he's gonna do anything
different regarding foreign policy
specifically the so-called forever wars
we are still in yeah i i think biden is
going to have a completely
uh reasonable foreign policy remember um
on drones barack obama was a disaster
but barack obama didn't start those
conflicts
um and you know i guess what i would say
to people who think biden's going to be
a neocon on foreign policy
who do you think he's going to start a
war with i actually i and i'm not asking
rhetorically
uh nicholas wants to primary chuck
schumer in 22
as a new yorker with theft view
with f-test view you think i would have
a chance
oh boy cameron says canada hopes for
biden
we do too adam says where can i download
the trump coronavirus remix songs you
play at the beginning of your show okay
if you go to google and you type joe
woodward soundcloud the first
result is the soundcloud with all of the
songs
all right very exciting stuff
brian holliday says what's the point of
republicans trying to get rid of the
affordable care act
you know i'm starting to think that
republicans are
treating the affordable care act almost
like roe v wade where
the promise of getting rid of it gets
people more activated
and raises more money than if they
actually were to get rid of it i think
if they were to get rid of the
affordable care act now it would be a
disaster
complete and total disaster thanks to
silky girl for both subscribing on
twitch
and gifting a subscription very much
appreciate that
um also want to say thanks to
oh i guess nobody else i guess that's it
all right
double deedee beat says i sended you
the winston video on facebook messenger
couldn't afford the link the link here
okay uh it's tough to uh
pull that up right now but okay i can
always do it on the next stream
joseph van scoy says given that the
house has already passed a bill to admit
dc
is the 51st state do you think it will
happen if we win the senate it would all
but guarantee two more democratic senate
seats
i'm 50 50. i if you say so as a
precondition if
biden wins and democrats take the senate
i think puerto rico becoming a state is
50 50
and i believe puerto rico will be voting
on that soon
but i could be wrong on that
let's see what else we've got here matt
bell says where is matt bell presumably
pedro will be a stand-alone video see
yes it will pedro video publishing over
the weekend
sam weaver says david how quickly will
trump start threatening to make out with
everyone in the audience tonight very
soon
very very soon
it looks like trump is about to land
williams says having witnessed
democratic infighting during the
primaries can independents and non-biden
democrats really be relied upon to win
this election no particular group can
ever be relied upon to win anything
but i believe the vast majority will
vote biden
unknown prodigy says how many hours do
you work a week over 50
you know i don't think so but back so
before the election when i was tracking
how many hours i was working a week i
was involved in a lot of different time
management
things and and different things um there
it was frequent that
i was i was right around 40 hours some
weeks 38 you know some 42.
um i mean i think now it's a little more
because of what's going on
but um no it's a you know everything's
good
pear tiran coming in with an extremely
powerful
thousand swedish kroner super chat which
now is by far
the biggest super chat of the evening
saying i think that the trump militia
will go nuts
but handled by the governors and
hopefully not military love from sweden
pair
you may be right you may be right
donald trump looks like he is arriving
remember uh i do have the option
for you to grab a membership on my
website
joinpakman.com this is the number one
funding source for our show
so if you like what i do if you
appreciate the streams and want to
continue
uh seeing them and supporting grab a
membership at joinpacman.com it is cheap
it is easy and it feels great and we
have a really modest goal of just 25
as you can see we're only at nine nine
out of 25.
every time somebody signs up this blue
bar fills up
uh and yesterday during the stream it
exploded off the screen i think we got
to about uh
130 or something like that which was
wild
and by the way if you want it to be dirt
cheap
use the coupon code 2020 now that'll
save you an additional 66
which is just incredible uh we are
seeing donald trump arrive here let's
make sure we are
uh fully in high definition always want
the best for you guys high definition is
here
let's see if there's an audio track
okay yeah there is and it's not good so
we will we're going to keep it here i
will be uh
thanking people uh from the standpoint
of memberships until trump starts
there's mark meadows as you can see
right over here behind donald trump
horrible guy i mean really just a bad
bad person
somebody who should we we would benefit
from uh removing from government
altogether
permanently um a few other super chats
oliver wilde says any other upcoming
notable interviews you would like to
promote
so i interviewed congresswoman debbie
mccarsell powell that will be airing
soon
also eric garcetti who is being
considered for a possible biden cabinet
or other position
the mayor of la he will be on this week
he will be on
my spanish show we will be interviewing
him in spanish eric garcetti much like
me
is a jewish latino um and then i will
have eric garcetti in english for the
english show which i think is going to
be great
um and then we have a few other notable
interviews
but i don't there's one that's really
big really really big and in fact
i want to follow up about it uh i'm
gonna follow up about it when trump
starts speaking because it's so big
and i was supposed to get an update in
fact let me get an update
um hey ryan
this doesn't give it away hey ryan any
update on this
would love to make the interview
happen this would be big big big big
arguably the biggest interview ever i
would say
um but that will be uh i'll have
information for you
you guys next week on that if indeed it
happens all right we are almost ready
for donald trump's uh corona rally let's
see uh what's happening
[Music]
okay it's still happening a couple other
super chats oscar says
a question about southern border camps
how are they affected by covid
now and later a hopefully biden
presidency well hopefully biden will
shut him down
and they are very very affected by kovid
sadly i wish they weren't but they are
95 says conservative belief system is
based on revenge and punishment
yeah it's called strict father morality
alright let's get into it here brace
yourselves guys
i love george here dude i love being
with you
this is georgia this is macon georgia
joe jackson we won macon we're going to
win it again it's great to be back
in the heart of this incredible state
with the thousands of loyal
hard-working unbelievable american
patriots how is he so sweaty already
and 18 days from now we're going to win
the state of georgia we're going to win
four more years
and that beautiful and incredible in so
many ways that beautiful white house
right
just remember early voting is underway
get out and vote
go out and vote
running against perhaps the worst
candidate in the history of presidential
politics
did you watch last night i mean give me
a break
but actually i wish it was a good
candidate because it actually puts more
pressure on you running against a guy
like this
sleepy joe biden is the living
embodiment
of the corrupt political class that
enriched itself while draining the
economic life and soul
from our country you know what's
happened you know very well in georgia
what happened
for the last 47 years joe biden shipped
away your jobs
shut down your factories threw open your
borders
and ravaged our cities while sacrificing
american blood and treasure
in endless and ridiculous foreign wars
in places you've never even heard of one
of the really interesting things to
watch during trump rallies is as the
masks
start coming down in the background
globalists and special interests
who got rich bleeding america dry and by
the way
i could call these guys every one of
them would give me millions i'm
president i called
heads of wall street firms i'd say hey
do me a favor could you give me five
million
every single i can't do that though
because you know what
if i do that i got to do things for them
and i don't want to do i want to do
what's right
i could call i could raise more
i could raise more money i'd be the
world's greatest fundraiser but i just
don't want to do it because then
you sort of say hey you know they
treated me good i got to treat them good
i know you don't think that's the way
the system works but that's the way the
system i guess works unfortunately
but it doesn't work that way for me in
2016 you voted to fire this corrupt
and decrepit political establishment and
you elected an
outsider as president to finally put
america first
and we've learned over the last couple
of months joe
biden is a corrupt politician he's a
corrupt politician
and the biden family is a criminal
enterprise
frankly it makes crooked hillary clinton
look like
an amateur clinton yikes
now whoever saw anything like this he
goes to china
the kid is following like a vacuum
cleaner he follows and follows and
followed
and unfortunately it sounds like he left
his laptop behind don't they have
thousands
who believes that he's a guy didn't have
a job but now he's taken in millions
and plenty of it goes to joe biden too
don't kid yourself that's an assertion
without any evidence see the one today
the guy gets 10 percent 10
i wonder who the guy is this was not a
good between
anthony weiner's laptop and this laptop
these are two beauties
i think this one could be worse than the
wiener laptop
yet this massive scandal is being
covered up
by the media and big tech right all
those people
this is deeply authoritarian
[Applause]
so here we have think of it here we have
the biggest scandal going on anywhere in
the world the corruption of joe biden in
the biden family
and he's interviewed last night by
stephanopoulos on nbc
and they don't even ask him the question
about it based on one story in the new
york post
which is very very weak three and a half
million dollars from moscow right from
moscow russia
because they were the ones involved with
russia it turns out not me it was the
opposite
but why did your son get three and a
half million
from the wife of the mayor of moscow
think of it
think of it a little question like that
remember chris wallace said oh well you
shouldn't ask him that question why now
is that
russia ukraine now he's known what are
you talking about now
but then the other one which is the
story a billion dollars get rid of the
prosecutor otherwise you don't get the
billion dollars from the united states
that's been debunked
but that's turning out to be peanuts
compared to what we're finding now
now he wants 10 million dollars from
china
to make an introduction would anybody
here take 10 million to introduce
somebody to your father
[Applause]
yeah dad i'd do it for 10 million bucks
they would wouldn't they
i would do it pop and he'd want me to do
a 10 million dad please
i had a great father i'm not just
running against biden and that corrupt
family i'm running against the left-wing
corrupt media
and we're running against big tech
[Applause]
everybody's the enemy
cnn sucks oh my god
what is happening to the country
this is a hell of a big crowd but look
at that that goes all the way around
the corona crowd
but you know the media they never show
it you ever notice you go home
they show me and about three people
behind me
people left right
four stars they end up three plus one
[Applause]
feeding the ego that could burst if it
got any bigger you know it's very
interest i love that but
no politician i believe has ever heard
that chant really
we are it's a cult somebody yeah it's a
cult
reagan i love reagan who's a wonderful
guy you never heard the chant we love
rankin with
you never heard that this started a few
weeks ago
and it's amazing and i appreciate it
very much i do
i appreciate it
okay
and i love this state i love georgia you
know when you had the hurricane
overdrive where it came in and wiped out
a lot of your
area david perdue is a fantastic guy who
may be here someplace
but david perdue called me said you got
to do me a favor you got to
help us with our farmers and we gave
them a hell of a lot of money we helped
they got wiped out by a hurricane you
know you don't hit too many hurricanes
right
but this was a big box anybody need a
mercy band of different
areas hit alabama we took care of
alabama we took care of georgia
we took care of georgia took care of our
farmers
i'll never forget i stood i came here
and i stood and i was with 32 farmers
all of them got hit hard and one of them
said sir i was a week away
from having the best crop i've ever had
and it got ripped apart just ripped
apart
it wasn't his fault and we took care of
him we took care of all of them okay and
it made me feel good
it made me feel good great people
and they never asked for anything they
just want a level playing field that's
all they ever wanted
and i raised by the way 28 billion thank
you china
because they targeted our farmers
12 billion and then the next year 16
billion dollars
frankly you did better without even
working if you want to know that
came from china and we did a hell of a
job and those farmers are all happy
today but they were targeted by china
we got 28 billion dollars in tariffs and
we gave it to your farmers
and everybody's uh doing just fine today
right
everybody's great i mean okay 220 000
died
but the radical left is doing everything
in their power
to protect their chosen candidate who
has no clue where he is
he's gone
they have nothing but disdain for you
and for your values and the values of
georgia i know georgia very well
they flood your communities with
criminal aliens
with drugs crime while leaving behind
and you see what they do they live in
gated communities but they flood you out
they complain about guns and they
complain about everything
and then they want to end yourself
hasn't trump lived in gated communities
his whole life themselves
they oppose school choice while sending
their families to the best private
schools
we need school choice by the way
[Applause]
people whose kids mostly go to public
school cheering cheering for ideas that
would make the public schools worse
so beautiful they demonize our great
police
and law enforcement while hiring private
security for themselves they attacked
the second amendment
every single day while employing armed
guards
and let me tell you i am the only thing
standing
in the way of you and your second
amendment it's under siege
that's a big deal
they support crippling lockdowns while
their jobs remain
totally exempt it's time we sent a
message to these
wealthy liberal hypocrites i could have
every one of them by the way
i mean just like i said before i can go
i know these guys i can call them all
hey do me a favor irving send me five
million okay i'll do it donald i'll do
it if you want it
five million for what oh man i gotta do
it do you mind if i take one week and
just do it i will set the
all-time record on fundraising man would
i be good at that it's so easy
i wouldn't have to explain a thing
but they come from washington they come
from new york this is a deeply ill man
valley and by the way
those silicon valley guys are sort of
getting caught aren't they huh
[Applause]
section 230 i'm sure most of you don't
know what that means
section 2 these guys they're given
powers they're given rights by
washington and then they claim free
speech
right they claim but no but they're
giving an exemption
and what's your health care policy again
and they can't abuse that power
and there's a lot of things going on
right now and
a lot of your people are looking we have
some of those people here you're great
congressmen senators and we'll be
introducing them in a second but they're
looking very hard at section 230.
on election day you can send a message
that the fake news media right there boy
there are a lot of them look at that
looks like the academy awards
it's a lot of people
[Applause]
there are a lot of people look at those
cameras they're all running with those
red lights but every time i mention
their name those red
lights go off you know that's never true
that means you're live and then they
start talking about it they say get the
light off
turn it off go to a break let's go to a
break right now
imagine believing that fake news cnn
they don't know what they
are so fake they really are they're just
disgusting
[Applause]
nbc is no better did you get to see less
so keeping an eye on the masks coming
off
the nose of this guy is now exposed this
woman has gone massless
throughout the event you see the masks
come off but i want to tell you that
she's like disappeared everybody thought
it was so inappropriate
here they give this guy softballs did
you see a week ago lester hall softballs
lester holt another genius leicester
here's mr vice president sir what did
you have for dinner sir
and in savannah it was like her face to
the anger the craziness
i mean the craziness last night and i
said goodbye i said great job savannah
you did wonderfully good job
but we got very high marks for that last
night i thought it was very
interesting ratings were better for
biden hilariously
that sleepy joe who cannot answer a
question he really can't answer a
question
well chris wallace protected him with me
i talked about
the moscow three and a half million
payment i talked about the billion
dollars
chris wallace wouldn't let the he said
no that's not appropriate why
he's allowed to take three and a half
million bucks so we're not allowed to
talk to him about it
doc i'm telling you that biden family
and others but that biden
family is corrupt it's a corrupt family
[Applause]
and with me and my kids let me tell you
i have to mute for this one
trump was asked yesterday did you get
tested on the day of the debate
at which we now suspect you had
coronavirus on the stage and and trump
said
i don't know maybe i was maybe i wasn't
and and he thinks
he came off looking good last night
can you imagine if my kids did what this
guy hunter is doing
ivanka oh my beautiful my wonderful
ivanka she's an inner she's a good oh
can you imagine not the dating ivanka
stuff again
and you know she's much smarter much
sharper she could if she wanted to how
could she
do well and don and eric and tiffany
they're just they're good kids
but you know we don't do things we don't
it's like boy
they'd make a fortune just think of it
and when you look at what they get away
with
and by the way biden's brother try that
one
i won't go too deep in the family i'm
not looking to insult everybody but
honestly
in my opinion it's a criminal enterprise
trump's not looking to insult people
could have fooled me
he's like a vacuum cleaner the father
goes through and the son comes in a
vacuum cleaner millions of dollars
pouring it
take a look at the way they live 47
years he's a politician he lives very
well
almost as well as maxine waters you ever
see her house
maxine maxine waters what a beautiful
house she lives in i wonder how that
happened
on election day you can send a message
that the
weird line of attack can't get away with
it any longer we can't let them get away
with it
[Music]
and these big tech companies you know
it's funny because i've heard about the
big tech companies i didn't care too
much and
i heard the power was unbelievable and
it's like 99
for the other side and i kept hearing
about big tech the power the power the
power that i ran i kept hearing it you
know what the hell
in one ear out the other but i kept
hearing and we won
so i kept hearing after that we won and
i said well wait a minute if they're so
powerful how come we won right they were
100
against us but now it's gotten worse and
worse and now they've gone
crazy they've gone crazy
how about our magnificent kaylee right
so kaylee
maybe the most dishonest press secretary
in history but they suspended her
account
because she posted an article from the
new york post which is one of the
largest papers in the country
which by the way i want to thank them
they've the one paper they've really got
guts they're printing this stuff they
got to be making a fortune as much as
industry nowadays but you know when you
look at the failing new york times and
the washington post they don't want to
write about it
they don't want to write it this is the
biggest political scandal it's the
likely fake story
political scandal the biggest political
scandal we caught them that's when they
spied on our campaign
i wish he would list the crimes list the
crimes obama committed please
second biggest political scandal these
are a bunch of bad people
and you think it's fun doing what i do
right
now i had a great life i want to tell
you i was doing well
i was having a lot of fun but you know
what i would never
give up what we've achieved think of
what we've achieved
i wish he would give it up honestly i
mean honestly there are a lot of
successful people there are a lot of
people there's success
a lot of them right here a lot of
successful people
but nobody in first three and a half
years nobody
first three and a half years nobody has
achieved
the history of our country what we've
achieved with our military with our tax
cuts with our regulations
with all of the things where someone
would say what have you achieved with
the military
you'd say oh we just bought a bunch of
planes and stuff bullets things like
right to try things like space force
thank you very much
you know i always get them i said turn
the cameras turn the cameras
so we just left florida we had a crowd
that was like like this it was
massive it went on forever turn the
camera
show the crowd corona crowd realize it's
actually good for them because it's
exciting it's like being in a
florida state florida ohio state if you
want to say
it's a massive football game what are
you talking about
distance where you have all these empty
seats right you'll be back very soon
you'll be
back very soon but but
and then of course georgia not bad
you're doing okay
[Applause]
but and who's the greatest of them all
from georgia
who's the greatest of them all from
georgia
herschel persia
by the way how good was herschel walker
[Music]
right
he made a lot of quarterbacks look good
hear her she'll run it boom
six yards nine yards 10 yards 100 yards
and he's on our side and he's an
incredible guy herschel walker
i remember when he was playing here all
right they had like the ballad
the ballad to herschel walker he was
like just a legendary guy remember
from the time he started just boom six
yards eight yards 10 yards
and then the quarterback goes he says i
think i'm going to sign with the nfl
it's like uh amazing but herschel's been
great and heard
the hell is he talking about and the
fact that we have his endorsement so
strongly
i mean so strongly we love it but what a
great football player he was what a
great
winner we want to thank kershaw the
ballot to herschel
on november 3rd show the people is he
saying
ballot or ballad that we're in charge
that we're delivering sleepy joe biden
in that whole group of radical left
crazies and by the way he's not really
radical left
but he's got no choice he's got
absolutely nothing going on we know he's
not radical
yeah how about kamala kamala oh my god
still can't say it
so how good did mike pence do a week ago
that was easy that was easy mike is
great he's doing a great job
and he really did he did a great job
where is mike but it's very unfair you
know it's so unfair
when you watch when you watch okay you
watch last night
and you see the anger and the hatred i'm
saying look
let's just do this thing just take it
easy relax
just relax take it nice and easy okay
okay she said but i told you that's true
right i said i don't believe you why
would i believe you
you know you see that where she's
screaming
i said well who told me i told you i
said who cares if you told me what are
you telling me
but we got very high marks but compare
that crystal clear
if joe biden was treated
like savannah guthrie treated us not me
it's us could you imagine
he would be freaked out he would
probably be under the table
he would be under the table and she's
easy compared to president xi
and putin in kim jong-un and plenty of
others she's like uh
easy pickings but could you imagine if
she came at him
did you see now this is sad in a way a
couple of weeks by
by george stephanopoulos and it was a
tough interview but it was fine i don't
say like you know give me
the answers and the questions do you
ever see where they
ask him a question and then he starts
reading the end that means he has the
answers to
i never saw anything like what's going
on in my entire
life they asked how about did you see
that
a week ago i said move it up a little
closer i can't read the damn answer
they that's been debunked already i mean
this is crazy
i am so proud of the fact yeah the sad
thing is it means that 60 million people
will vote for this insanity that's the
real sad thing
and they'll still live here even if he
loses
look at all that equipment it's millions
of dollars worth of equipment
[Applause]
and you know what if they were truthful
our country would come together so fast
it's really true
they're a big part of the problem i was
saying today i was telling you
when i was in florida i was telling the
story that you know our people
we're going to bring it all together and
they said how are you going to do it
through success
because we were ready we had the most
successful economy we've ever had we
never had an economy
african-american hispanic american
asian-american
women people with high school diplomas
people without high school
diplomas people from mit top of their
class
geniuses physicists chemical engineers
sorry guys a lot going on here drop my
mouth
sent to us by china we're not going to
forget that i'm not going to forget that
we're not going to forget it and they
know we're not going to forget it they
know it damn well then we're not going
to forget it
and now we're we closed it down we saved
millions of lives they don't say that
you know
we're over 200 000 that's terrible but
compared to other nations it's
it's uh amazing what we've been able
eighth highest per capita death rate
eighth highest per capita case rate
lives right
and we saved millions of lives and now
we're rebuilding it back and our economy
is setting records what we're doing is
setting
up but if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician is because i'm not
a politician
ball addition that's weird and if i
don't always play by the rules of the
washington establishment
and it would make like you know it would
make my life a lot easier to be honest i
know how to play those roles
remember they used to say and i used to
play the game about acting presidential
i'm a smart guy we're a lot of smart
people here i'm smart
and i always said it's much easier to be
presidential
to do what i do right remember
and i said i'm more presidential if i
wanted to be but i got to get things
done i don't have enough time there's so
many stupid things that happen with
bad deals stupid deals bad drinks
but do you remember i used to go and i
would have fun but i'd used to go and
i'd imitate
a president who's playing presidential
that's so easy compared to what we do
what we do is much more difficult i said
i can be more presidential than any
president in our history with the
possible exception of
abraham lincoln when he wore the hat
have i missed the policy part of the
scene
but you remember i did we had fun with
it we'd say
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen of georgia
this is your president and it is a great
honor to be with you
tonight things are going very
well with our country
our military is building
and you know so i could do that and you
know within about three minutes
everybody would pick up and they'd say
let's get that out of here this guy's
now we're doing a great job we're
renegotiating these horrible trade deals
we're bringing our people
back home verbal inkblot
it's all over because i was elected
[Music]
to fight for you and i fight harder for
you than any president has ever
fought for the people of this country
what's going on
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you by the way i have to tell you
the spirit in this country is
unbelievable but the spirit in these
rallies
are unbelievable and and you know hey
we were in minnesota we're going to win
minnesota you know minnesota i think
hasn't been one since 1972.
you'll notice excuse the mute but this
is important we now have three
unmasked women here it does sort of seem
to spread by contagion
um we now have three women who have
removed their masks
uh all next to each other and we're
seeing more and more noses pop up it's
bizarre how it spreads at these things
i gave it back to the people of maine
we're doing things that nobody's
uh nobody's ever thought about doing
ever done
we went into you take a look at take a
look at
minneapolis the place was burning down
the national guard goes in 30 minutes
would you say
remember they formed that beautiful
scene after watching this for a week and
a half
and we want to do it with portland
portland would be so easy
wise guys they're just wise guys these
are wise guys in there
you know you had the one guy who killed
somebody in the street took him three
days to arrest i sent in
the u.s marshals you know
15 minutes later it was over i said why
hasn't that guy been
they all knew who they were putting his
picture up i said why hasn't he been
arrested well sir there however
i said really you got another day we
sent in the u.s marshals in 15 minutes
we have the greatest law enforcement
people in the world
15 minutes later it was all over for him
but the forces opposing me in washington
are the same people
who are responsible for every disastrous
trade deal
foreign policy blunder and border
security betrayal thanks oliver well
said
our border our southern border is so
great by the way we've topped
400 miles of wall
i'm i'm much more horrified by 220 000
deaths he keeps talking about 400 miles
of walls
very soon but it's had an incredible
impact our border has never been as good
we got rid of catch and release all the
stuff that everybody said would be
impossible
but it's been incredible and mexico is
paying for the world you do know they're
not i don't know if you guys have
noticed but for months he's been saying
we're at 390 miles
now he says 400 but we're building 10 a
week the numbers don't add up that but
they don't like to say it no
we're doing uh some incredible things
this is the most
important election in the history of our
country and i used to even two
three months ago i said well you know
this is like very important but 2016 was
important
this is more important this is more
that's true success will bring us
together as i was saying
but you know what else is going to bring
us together a victory because they're
just going to finally say
let's just give up
they're going to say beat them into
submissions people can't be beaten
they're going to say these people
can't be beaten and many of them were so
happy two weeks ago they heard trump
tested positive they were so happy and
then i got out like right away here i am
like a long time i could have come
[Music]
what an insane speech
they say can you imagine he won't be
able to hold any more rallies he'll be
recovering or worse or worse
they'll be recovering or worse and like
uh 12 minutes later here we are you know
like
don't forget i was i've been doing this
for a long time already this is not my
first rally right but all these rallies
are like this the spirit of this country
is unbelievable
and that's what we have and even the
fake news admits we have
more enthusiasm than any candidate
in the history of this country
and he has less enthusiasm in my opinion
than any candidate
i think he's the weakest candidate in
the history of presidential politics
we will see with all of that being said
they have a corrupt media
they have big tech they have all of this
stuff it's a very powerful party
and they have advantages you know they
automatically win new york i don't know
why new york is doing so badly because
people vote automatically win california
i don't know why
california is doing so badly the forest
fires no water
no there's no that you know minor little
problems they automatically win
illinois i mean we got to run the table
we got it's automatic because it's just
the way it falls
you know winning the electoral college
is a very very sort of like trump
automatically wins louisiana mississippi
north dakota south dakota i mean
what is he talking about but we're
winning in florida
we're winning here
you know it's amazing like if he came
here sleepy joe if he came here
honestly if they announced they'd work
really hard to try and find people
no i really mean this we have tens of
thousands look at this this thing goes
back
way way back i wish they wouldn't give
these guys a good look i wish they'd
moved them back 100. again with the tens
of thousands and i'm telling my people i
just i'll save a little time
my people please from now on could you
please move the fake news media back
like another 100 yards
nothing more in line with western
democracy than perpetually attacking the
media
you know what those cameras they have
magnifiers on they can be back
and you can get a lot of people so
instead of standing behind the camera
and looking at the cameraman's ass we
don't need that
okay just move them back and we get more
people up here because it goes back
forever
thank you back there we love you thank
you but we're going to move it back
move them back
this can only happen in georgia you know
i have an idea just gave me an idea
we'll have a new t-shirt tomorrow
morning
move them back
well we did it with you know we did it
with this crazy hunter hunter biden
remember where's hunter i kept saying
where the hell is hunter cause he was
gone you know they caught him stealing a
lot of money
so he like disappeared remember and wait
now he's saying but hunter stole the
money
that's a great idea for a t-shirt we
came out with a t-shirt
where's hunter it became one of the big
successes of the year
when it comes to t-shirt salesman
basically
we were talking today about drug prices
and you know in this country we have a
very bad system and we have middlemen
that are very rich
and i was talking about how we're
cutting out the middlemen oh these are
not people that like me very much
he was target about it and all that
stuff we're getting your
drug prices down 60 70 80 but the
middlemen
the middlemen are making all of this
money tremendous they're
very wealthy they don't even do anything
frankly at least the drug companies they
make the drug
so we're talking about we're talking
about the middlemen
and i say wait a minute i think i know
one of the middlemen it must be hunter
hunter biden is a middleman
on top of everything else china ukraine
russia plus he's a middleman ah what a
family
in exchange and that's what he's done
it's a corrupt bargain in exchange for
his
party's nomination back on the prompter
should have gone to bernie
you know elizabeth warren pocahontas
if she would have left a day before
super tuesday joe biden would not have
won any of those states
so this guy now has fully removed his
mask as you can see we got another nose
out down
here it just progresses during the rally
sanders
is the nicest greatest loser i've ever
seen because
now it's true and i mean this and you
know we're going to get a lot of their
votes because they love us on trade
because the one thing bernie's right on
is every
country in this world including our
so-called allies
excuse me are there any children in the
house
okay close your ears children screw us
on trade
and bernie's people and bernie's into
the problem is bernie wouldn't be able
to do anything about i've done a lot
about it
i've done a lot about it but you know
that's why we got a lot
we got a big percentage of bernie people
and because they didn't like hillary but
they don't like joe
and uh we're gonna get a lot of burning
people so i have to be nice to bernie
but i consider him a really good loser
because he loses with such he's so nice
about it he loses
i mean what she did to him was bad but
this was in a way worse because
all elizabeth warren had to do is leave
the campaign didn't even have to endorse
him and he would have gotten votes and
he would have won
every single state on super tuesday and
that didn't happen
and so now we have a guy with a little
bit larger base but no energy
here we would have had somebody with a
smaller base but with tremendous energy
but not as much energy as we do and we
have a big base so
i like that either crystal clear no that
makes a lot of sense i know exactly what
point he's making a complex story but
what the hell are you the most complex
time right what the hell good awareness
to notice it in exchange for his party's
nomination he's uh handed control
and you know that in exchange to the
socialists and the marxist
and the far left name him
if he wins the radical left we'll be
running this country
they're addicted to power and god help
our country if that happens i really
mean it you'll never make a comeback
it'll be a large-scale version of
venezuela trump will be fine you'll be
screwed
i've never meant it like i mean it now
the only difference is the size
because the ideology is the same
venezuela 20 years ago less
was so wealthy one of the wealthiest
countries it had oil it had everything
very very magnificent now they don't
have water
they don't have medicine they don't have
food
everyone's fleeing the country you know
the only difference is the size
but the ideology when you look at a
portland i want them to let us in
i said governor of oregon i said let us
come in i want to solve your problem
but they're radical left democrats you
know it's just like the craziest thing
but that's what venezuela is they're
anarchists
you look at some of these cities they're
anarchists and biden's campaign has
nothing in common with venezuela and we
originally had a hard time
we had a hard time they didn't want us
to have any rallies in certain states
and then i realized you're not allowed
to go to church
you're not allowed to have dinner with
people you're not allowed to do anything
unless in michigan you happen to be
married to the governor because her
husband
you're not allowed to go sailing unless
you're married to the governor
of michigan in which case you can go
sailing remember that
did she get caught or what
[Music]
now she's blaming me because people were
whatever i don't know what's going on i
don't know i wasn't
and it was our people that caught them
trump wasn't involved in the plot to
kidnap her okay that's good good to know
and yet we did a favor who knows i mean
they have to look at that whole thing
too
but we are doing an incredible job in
this country this country is great
and we have spirit like nobody's had
spirit
and there's going to be a red wave next
week
that's going to be unbelievable and
they're talking about it
look at that it's millions of dollars
worth of equipment
and they'll never turn it around to show
those people back there because they
want to say
donald trump had a rally in georgia
there was a smattering of people a
smallest battery
no it's uh amazing nobody's ever had
what we've had
this guy's nose out now continuing we
have one of these characters standing
right there
he said it could be a red wave don't say
there could be there will be it's going
to be a wave
and they don't want to go the phony uh
unsolicited ballot
you know they send ballots out by the
millions they don't have no idea
well they do actually have an idea where
they're going that's what really
but we say who's sending them where are
they going
who's getting them who's delivering them
who's signing them
what the hell are they doing
and then if you say that they go he's
not for freedom
he's not for freedom and they know
better than you do it's a big con job
so we have to be very careful with the
ballots because
it's hard to even take this remotely
seriously i mean obviously i don't but
military ballots it's hard to imagine
anyone taking it seriously
garbage can 60 million will vote for 50
000 ballots
from ohio they find them from north
carolina
dumped in a river they find them i think
500
000 ballots in virginia they were
incorrect they're printing them wrong
they had one little problem on one set
of ballots thousands and thousands
thousands they forgot to put the name of
donald trump on the ballot
other than that the ballot was quite
good okay
and great balance about this these
people
are doing a tremendous disservice and
they're using kovid
as the reason you know they're using
they're using this
as a reason not to go out and vote so we
voted in world war one
where by the way you had a pandemic
that made this look like peanuts okay oh
god here we go world war one
they voted in world war one they voted
in world war
ii they voted during the great
depression they voted voted voted
but we can't do that you got to send in
a ballot so complicated
they have instructions you do the ballot
then you do this
but some of them make it nice and simple
you don't have to sign
you don't have to verify but what they
don't tell you is we've won a lot of
court cases
how about you put your ballot in and it
has to be in by november third
but you have two weeks in which to get
so one man you have two weeks to count
them
does that mean we have to hold up the
whole election because you know what
i want to find out who won a lost i want
to find out
it's getting awkward yeah on november
3rd i'm not looking to find out
i'm not looking to find out on november
19th
or on december 1st or on two years from
now
and if you take a look at some of these
ballot schemes
in new york we had one third great
politician named carolyn maloney who i
know very well she used to come to my
office all the time for campaign
contributions
but she won a race the number of ballots
missing
they have no idea her opponent who could
have won it was very close but they
declared her the winner
but her opponent has gone totally nuts
and you know what he should another mask
has come off here
this woman crying or gentlemen i'm not
sure this person is crying apparently
wiping their eyes mask off
and they'll say even i must say even in
18 they had a lot of disasters
and even in 16 i didn't even know it but
they had a lot of
ballots i i promise you it will be
against us
okay it will be against us it looks like
this woman's really messing with the
mask a lot i think this one's coming off
soon
nevada but they're sending ballots to
everybody the governor was a
backroom politician and
i don't want him having the fate of an
election i don't think it's right
that he has the fate of our most
important election ever in his hands i
don't want that
so if you see anything wrong law
enforcement's watching
marshals or u.s marshals are watching
same type of guys these
are no games people one thing i'm saying
law enforcement they're on our side
and i said it maybe he shouldn't speak
for them
debate with joe i said joe name one law
enforcement group that's supporting you
he couldn't do it then he was bailed out
by chris wallace
right i said name one law enforcement
then i said here joe
just say the words law and order say
those words joe
he didn't want to say it i said joe just
say the words lord
law and order of course biden did say it
he said law and order
and justice wouldn't say it he wouldn't
say it then he tried i think he said law
and order and safety and security you
know because because he has to get the
vote of the radical left and they don't
like
law and order and you know who likes
trump because of law and order
the suburban women
i keep hearing because they want law and
order
and i got a look at that thank you same
thing happened four years ago
same thing they said women will not vote
for trump
women will not then the election's over
they said man the women really came out
and voted for trump right
but suburban women
i keep saying suburban women and i got
rid of a regulation that would have
destroyed the value of your homes
oh no and would have made your homes
very unsafe
with low income health every time he
talks about this the regulation does
something totally different
and even my people they said sir you
don't have to determine we can make it
much weaker i said no no you don't
understand
i want it terminated terminated and i
terminated it
suburban women please thank you very
much
all right sir
no i heard they they like my policy but
they don't like my personality i said
they don't care about my personality
they want to be
safe and they want to keep their
american dream
they don't care about my personality
which i think is okay
they like my personality the mask works
really less
as an earring i like them i love them
the radical left is hell-bent on
destroying everything that we love
culture stuff right cancel culture they
want cancel culture they want to get rid
of our great
heroes from the past they want to get
rid of our history i want to get rid of
our culture
right i was at mount rushmore they want
to blow
a mount rushmore up i said to our great
governor of south dakota
christy i said christy it's never
happening christy don't worry about it
she said you don't have to
we don't even need your help for this
one it was so beautiful mountain rush
but they want to blow it up
i said not going to happen none of that
stuff is going to happen
but i will tell you a few months ago if
i weren't your president
you would have had the jefferson
memorial
the lincoln memoir how about lincoln
they want to attack even lincoln
he's probably looking down and he's
saying what the hell did i do i was on
their side i think right
what did i do they want to attack the
lincoln if i wasn't
your president they would have attacked
the jefferson memorial
and i stopped it i stopped a lot of
things i also saved your second
amendment by the way
saved it we wouldn't even have it want
to punish the middle class
[Music]
expunge trump wants us to believe that
we're not for him
an amendment uh undoing
the second amendment could have been
passed when most
governors are republicans how exactly
would that happen contempt for the
united states
and i don't think biden does but biden
has no power he's got he's gone
he's gone up here he's gone the
republican party
is proud of america we're proud of
america we love america
we celebrate american values american
history and american culture
and we're working to deliver a truly
extraordinary
american future but i want the
republican party to get tougher
because the republican party they're
very good people but they're not tough
enough
in terms of our values and what we stand
for
they let these other people these
lunatics get away with things
like you can't spy on a campaign
you can't try and
take over a duly elected president of
the united states
and get caught and when you get caught
you have to
suffer the consequences it's very simple
yeah joe biden and the democrat
socialists
will kill your jobs dismantle your
police departments and you see that
going all over with seattle and all
and by the way seattle so they knew we
were going in the following day
so the night before they raised their
hands and they left okay
very simple i said that's it whether
they like us in there or not we're going
in they took over a big piece of the
city
and they weren't going to do anything
they knew we were going in go on so the
night before they said you know these
are little facts that i give you just to
give you because that's the way it works
they're supposed to
ask us the governors are supposed to ask
us but these radical left
you know if you look at republican-run
states and cities they're doing
phenomenally well never done better
but if you look at these radical left
look at what happened to my beautiful
new york
since i left three and a half years it
was doing great
and i left i'm not saying because but
i'd love for him to talk about
corvid 19. i came to washington what's
happened to new york what they've done
to that
incredible city and state is so sad
look at chicago look at what's going on
there look at what's going on
atlanta look at atlanta it's so sad
what's going on
and these are radical left no bail no
cash bail no
nothing i mean you kill somebody no
problem
no problem they're gonna have to get
their act together
they're going to have to get their act
together because we're not going to put
up with it much longer
they want to dissolve your borders
release criminal aliens
raise your taxes and by the way i'm
cutting your taxes big
biden this guy
oh biden wants to substantially raise
your taxes
and then he says well i'm only talking
about people i said no no no he wants to
terminate the tax cuts that we gave you
so that's 2
000 and then you look at the energy cuts
and you look at the child
tax credit so we did an analysis this
week feels like last week of the tax
plan and obviously all of these are lies
it's impossible to refute everything one
by one
terminated that means that's nine
thousand dollars well i don't know about
that you know then he pulls out a piece
of paper and he starts reading it out of
his
did you see that yes they pulled out a
piece of paper because he couldn't
remember any of the numbers he pulls out
and george stephanopoulos is sitting
there watching this
he didn't treat me as nice you know so i
did him two weeks ago too he did him
he was fine you know it is what it is
right he's going to ask me a question
right
you know the expression he asks you a
question i give him an answer
that's all you can do right you can't do
any better than that but they were nasty
you know pretty nasty and not terrible
but pretty
pretty nasty she was out of line i mean
in my opinion
she was out of line how dare savannah
guthrie called trump out for his obvious
lies
but when you watch the one the week
before it's just so it's such a
difference
the beauty is the people of our country
get it they're smart they get it
they get it 60 million voted for you
dude how smart could they be nbc owned
by
comcast c-o-n i'd call it concass you
know it used to be
calm they spend a fortune on public
relations and i come along and call them
comcast all the time
it's a con job they want to confiscate
your guns
drive god from the public square and
abolish the suburbs that's what they
want
and the suburbs everything will be city
constitution from this badness
i proudly nominated judge amy
coney barrett to the united states of
florida
[Music]
imagine cheering for that
amy covered barrett
[Applause]
she's great she's so smart
she's so smart right she's done a great
job
she's done a great job and she went
through it
no problem and they came at her they
came at her it was like
it was like uh your atlanta team
when they were good a couple of years
ago how the hell did they lose that
super bowl could you
how the hell did that happen i keep
thinking man
if you owned that team or you worked for
that team that was like uh that was a
long shot but
you know it's one of those things but
that was like that team
playing a high school football team
right she was so much
more talented than those people that
were trying to embarrass her
and she was cool as hell the coolest was
do you have notes
do you have notes
right a blank
no yeah if you don't plan to answer any
questions you don't really need notes
and most of this has been off this
teleprompter because it was on the
teleprompter
many of you would say this is a little
boring let's get out of here sam
last night biden refused to rule out
court back in other words they may take
16
17 18 people he'll pack the court with
radical
left judges who will shred your second
amendment
disarm law-abiding citizens and protect
terrorists guys headed out violent
criminals you know i won
the ban from jihadist countries or other
countries if people are bad we don't
want them in
so i went for the ban everybody said but
i won i wanted the supreme court
and you know what we don't want people
that can't love our country we don't
want people that are going to hurt
our country so i have a band very
controversial
and we won at the united states supreme
court and we don't let people in from
certain countries that are going to look
to do bad things so it's pretty amazing
what's happened doesn't it
biden's agenda would also be a
catastrophe
for georgia seniors seniors
that's not true how many seniors in the
house
right the guy without the mask raised
his hand
can you imagine guys
guy raised his hand as a now biden is
pledging mass amnesty
and free health care for illegal aliens
decimating medicare and destroying your
social security because that's what's
going to happen
you know we all have a heart i say this
all the time i mean yeah biden has no
plan whatsoever to destroy social
security so i think guys we uh
we've gotten a sense of what donald
trump is offering here tonight it's
essentially the same message a little
bit less orange
and a little bit more unhinged so that
is going to
end my coverage of this event i would
advise you for health and safety reasons
not to go watch it anywhere else
i think you've probably had all you can
um
uh health-wise at this point uh but if
you must
you can continue elsewhere i will be
back at some point
with another stream i appreciate
everybody joining me
to the extent that you did and i will
see you very very soon